let's start with something a little
different today over the last few weeks
I started getting emails like this one
that I'm putting up on the screen saying
David now that Joe Rogan has been proven
right about the vaccines now that
Russell Brand and Kim Iverson have been
proven right about the vaccines and you
were wrong
are you going to apologize are you going
to issue a retraction or a traction for
the Howard Stern fans to what you said
now initially I had no idea what these
people were talking about but indeed
there are a whole bunch of Clips out
there from people like Jimmy Dore a
video called Joe Rogan proven right
about vaccines and myocarditis Russell
Brand did a video myocarditis and Matt
Hancock the great covid swindle a woman
named Kim Iverson who I guess only does
vaccine content now when I looked at her
channel it's like just months of only
vaccine stuff she did a video why
Florida halts covet mRNA for men 18 to
39 and then she also did a video in
August called massive study proves men
under 40 have a higher risk of
myocarditis
post-vaccination so they are claiming
that they have been Vindicated and some
of my viewers are writing to me and
saying David all of these people have
been Vindicated and you were wrong so
let's see if we can talk this through
the first question is what they believe
is Vindication is they say they are
right to be skeptical and reluctant
about the covet vaccine because of
myocarditis and that that has now been
Vindicated now the first part of this
that's sort of strange
is that all of these videos came out in
early to mid-november and one in August
that I talked about and yet the study
that they are all talking about was
published in April of this year that's
almost eight months ago huh
strange right I mean the study is
published eight months ago and they all
talk about it within a few days of each
other in November
that should at least raise a question
and it said all should also make us
wonder if all of these videos were
produced in November but they're talking
about an April study is there any other
study data that came out between April
and November that they excluded from
their videos well we're going to figure
that out but let's start with the study
from April the big takeaway from the
April study is that men under the age of
40
have a higher risk of myocarditis
post-vaccination compared to those who
have not been vaccinated now the study
actually says in it quote further
long-term studies will be needed to
estimate the incidence of pericarditis
and myocarditis in patients diagnosed
with covid this is critical
it's not new information that there is a
small risk of pericarditis and
myocarditis particularly to younger men
from the MRNA covet vaccines we knew
that it was a known risk very rare but a
known risk so that part isn't actually
news but what these folks want to imply
and some of them are straight up saying
is that the risk of pericarditis and
myocarditis from covid is lower than
that from the vaccine in other words the
vaccine is more dangerous than covid the
study they are citing specifically
doesn't say that it says you've got to
study that in order to figure out what
is the incidence of pericarditis and
myocarditis in people who get coveted
that's number one so what they are
implying the study doesn't actually say
secondly no one claimed the vaccine had
no risks nobody claimed there were we
all talked about the side effects this
specific risk was known and it was
Quantified and it's really rare So
pretending that learning that is
newsworthy also is dishonest now the
more you delve into the data and again
they're saying here's a study from April
there are newer studies which we will
get to but this they want to focus on
this study from April the more you delve
into the data
the less stunning and shocking and
surprising that the data is an article
from the American College of Cardiology
called which covet vaccine you get can
impact myocarditis risk comments on the
study and clarifies that quote incidence
of myocarditis is two to three fold
higher after the second dose of the
moderna vaccine when compared to the
Pfizer vaccine however overall cases of
heart inflammation with either vaccine
are very rare this is super important
because again the studies from April we
already knew this we already knew
there's a slightly higher risk of
myocarditis from the vaccine it's
slightly higher from the moderna than
the Pfizer vaccine but the super
important part is you know how sometimes
you hear these claims Health claims and
I'm making this one up this is an
imaginary Health claim but it'll go
something like this
eating persimmon
doubles your risk of spontaneous
blindness this is a joke okay we're
making this up eating persimmon doubles
your risk of spontaneous blindness and
then you find out the risk of
spontaneous blindness in the general
population is 0.01 percent
and the people who ate persimmon went
randomly blind twice as frequently
0.02 percent of the time right is that
significant is that something that you
would alter your behavior around
particularly if eating persimmon had
other health benefits
that's an important analogy to what is
being talked about here now many doctors
including guy whitberg who's an MD and
an mph he's a cardiologist at the rabine
medical center in Israel
he said this information suggests that
if you have any kind of underlying
cardiovascular disease get the Pfizer
vaccine instead of the moderna that's a
doctor's takeaway from this study that's
the takeaway now to go further
many other studies don't even find that
myocarditis is more prevalent in those
that take a vaccine versus who don't
take a vaccine so they're talking in
November about an April study there are
newer studies that don't replicate this
result in August of 2022 but uh this
August right I mean three months ago the
American Heart Association published a
study reporting that quote the risk of
myocarditis is greater after a covet
infection than after covet vaccination
and remains modest after sequential
doses of the booster however the risk of
myocarditis after vaccination is higher
in younger men particularly after a
second dose of the MRNA vaccine
information we knew mostly and making it
clear it seems that covid carries the
higher risk that happens to come from a
study which was published in August of
this year now that is a four-month newer
study than the one Jimmy Dore and
Russell Brand and Kim Iverson are
looking at
meaning they chose or didn't care or
didn't look to see are there newer
studies that conflict with the one from
April that we're all titillated by but
we have something kind of even more
interesting and it's even newer
information an October study so this is
last month from Penn State College
called quote myocarditis induced by
covet infection is substantially greater
than the risk posed by vaccines
this study found myocarditis in induced
by covid infections is worse than that
myocarditis induced by the vaccines okay
that's from last month and the other
part of this is
even if you imagine that the risk of
myocarditis is higher from the vaccine
than it is from covid or rather that
they are the same if you say okay well
myocarditis is is more likely when you
get a vaccine and it's more likely when
you get coveted imagine that we Grant
both of those equally
the myocarditis associated with the
vaccine is milder than the myocarditis
associated with covet that's an
important consideration
a Dr Nicola Klein who's a vaccine expert
at Kaiser Permanente says quote
vaccine-associated myocarditis is
usually milder than the viral type
that's if the risks were equal and many
studies say that's not the case many
studies find this and we're putting
another article up on the screen
here is how some of the commentators I
just mentioned reported on this Jimmy
Dore when talking about this said before
we give forgiveness for the people who
were Nazis around covid policy who were
pro-lockdown pro-mandates and they were
100 wrong on all that stuff it's okay to
be wrong about that stuff what's not
okay is to then demonize people who
disagree with you on facts
well what are the facts choosing an
eight-month-old study when there are
newer studies multiple newer studies
that disagree I don't know
so that's what's going on there's no
retraction needed there's no apology
needed most of this study comes out with
information that's not new
the parts that are more
notable have already been contradicted
by multiple newer studies I have no
horse in this race I want the truth and
I want the healthiest Public Health
situation for everybody
that's it so uh that is the information
as I know it if you have additional
information I should be considering or
evaluating by all means send it to me if
you like these types of segments make
sure to subscribe on YouTube on the page
for this video like if you're watching
this video right now hit subscribe we
see the analytics of which Clips
generate subscribers and if this is of
interest to the audience we will
absolutely do more of these we're going
to take a quick break and be right back
one of our sponsors is all form the
easiest way to design your own custom
sofa I have one from all form unlike
other companies all form lets you choose
the fabric the size the shape color even
the color of the legs I have not one but
two all form sofas I've had them for
years they look good as new definitely
the most comfortable Furniture I own and
it gets even cooler because all form
sofas are completely modular you can buy
a sofa and if you move you can adapt it
to the new space by adding on to it or
rearranging its elements that is
definitely not something you get from
your typical Sofa Company all form has
everything from eight piece sectionals
to love seats and arm chairs everything
is made in the USA using premium
materials all form makes sure that
assembly is really easy I didn't even
need any tools which is good because I
have very few tools and you can keep the
sofa for over three months and send it
back free if you don't like it for a
full refund right now all form is giving
my audience 20 off all orders at
allform.com Pacman the link is down
below